my friends i've come to tell you
something about slavery our newspapers
are daily disfigured by its ghastly
horrors
imagine that you had to dispel doubts
about your full humanity every time you
picked up a pen
having to fight that battle over and
over every day
that was the life of frederick douglass
i feel that i have a right to speak and
to speak strongly we need the storm the
whirlwind and the earthquake more than
20 years of my life were consumed in a
state of slavery i feel bound to speak
truly he had a gift as a storyteller he
had an unforgettable voice stop telling
them they can't fight and tell them they
can fight it became an american
phenomenon to see douglas overthrow this
system of slavery which is crushing them
to the earth he has the role as the
spokesman of black america there is no
model for who he is
i think douglas thought that he
single-handedly was charged with the
task of refuting every racist stereotype
about black people through one means
his voice
[Music]
you